light some fireworks and watch your
grandmother commit murder because
detective holmes is on the case
no not that one or that one or that one
much better enola holmes is netflix's
latest adventure caper starring millie
bobby brown as sherlock holmes's cunning
and fearless younger sister
so come along with me as we take a deep
dive into the mystery and solve how this
guy plays the best evil british man
in every role he plays but before we get
into it make sure to like and subscribe
so you won't miss any of the latest
videos enola spells alone backwards just
like if you rearrange
think story you get stinky thor for much
of her life anola has been alone with
only her mother beatrix lestrange as her
only friend
her father died when she was young and
her older brothers mycroft and sherlock
are
so absorbed in their own lives they're
never around they're so oblivious to
anola that when she comes to pick them
up at the train station they don't even
recognize her well enola is pretty
steadfast in her ways throughout the
entirety of the film it's
actually sherlock who i'd argue
undergoes the most change anola
confronts him about how he never visits
or
writes mycroft even says you never cared
about her before
she's only 16. sherlock is continually
confronted by his abandonment of both
his mother
and enola and only when anola goes
missing does mrs lane tell him straight
up
you've already abandoned her once sir
i'm asking that you don't abandon her
again
sherlock spends the rest of the film
searching for his sister eventually
telling mycroft that he will take her on
as his ward
he won't abandon her again but the real
story centers around enola and her
search for her mother
she needs to realize that while her name
spells alone backwards being alone
doesn't mean you're lonely
being alone doesn't mean i have to be
lonely she wanted me to find
my freedom my future
my purpose and that's what enola's
journey is all about
finding herself in a world that is
changing just as rapidly as herself
she needs to find her place in this
world rather than others finding it for
her
there are two pearls you can take in
ella yours
or the path others choose for you on the
other hand mycroft wants enola to
conform to the traditional ways of
society
for her to find and serve a husband as
the obedient wife
she's later taken to miss harrison's
school for young ladies where she learns
such important skills like
how to properly laugh
embroider and walk contrast this to what
her mother taught her
jiu-jitsu science and archery enola
homes is all about carving your own path
and not conforming to a world that seeks
to control you
and mycroft is the perfect encapsulation
of this
you want me controlled because otherwise
you think i will affect your standards
yeah you
are my ward and you will do as you are
told the real story begins when anola's
mother mysteriously vanishes leaving
anola a gift wrapped in purple cloth
purple was often a color used by the
suffragettes in their fight for the vote
and we'll see at eudoria's secret female
meetup that they all wear purple ribbons
as well as the purple ribbon that
denotes the location of one of their
hideouts
although the events in the movie take
place around the year 1900 it wouldn't
be until 1903
the women's social and political union
was founded in the uk
whose members later became known as
suffragettes her journey takes her on a
train to london where she meets the vi
count of tewksbury on the run from his
overbearing family
like canola his family and society have
dictated what his life will be
he'll end up joining the military like
his father and uncle
and become a lord something he's scared
he'll hate every minute of
they form a bond two people fighting
against a system that has forced them to
be
something they aren't in london enola
searches for edith grayston a woman who
corresponded with her mother regularly
and who also happens to run a sweet
jujitsu class for women above a t-shirt
in a brief tussle anola attempts the
corkscrew a difficult jiu-jitsu move
that she doesn't quite pull off
but it's a great setup since she'll use
this very same move to take down one of
the film's villains in the final act
i know jiu jitsu i know kung fu enola
uses her powers of deduction and
realizes the name
ellie houseman a word she heard her
mother say during the secret meeting
isn't a name at all when you rearrange
the letters you get a location
lime house lane which leads her to a
warehouse filled with bombs used by the
suffragettes there are
instances of women using violence in
their fight for equal rights
christabel pankhurst one of the leaders
of the movement in britain said
if men throw a bomb that destroys other
people it is then described as a
glorious and heroic deed
why should a woman not make use of the
same weapons as men
it is not only war we have declared we
are fighting for a revolution her
investigation is short-lived when she's
attacked by the man in the bowler hat
who is looking for lord tewkesbury and
this is where not being your average
girl comes to her advantage as she's
able to fight him off and escape
later recounting a story of her as a
child saving a sheep from a cliff that
almost got her killed
we actually see this in a quick
flashback near the end of the film
enola is one to put her life on the line
for those that are vulnerable and right
now she knows lord tewkesbury is in need
a murderer is after him and she's
compelled to help
just like she helped that sheep years
ago in search of answers she heads to
the tewksbury's posing as both a widow
and sherlock holmes's assistant
we meet inspector lestrade from scotland
yard who's been assigned the case
fun fact lestrade is an anagram for
dearest l
a reference to author sir arthur conan
doyle's first wife louisa
she ends up being chased away finding
the vi count's treehouse and getaway
plan which will later lead her to his
location
at covent garden market cause you know
he loves flowers and stuff but more
interesting are in nola's discovery of
the cut down tree
and her conversation with the dowager or
lord tewksbury's grandmother we'll later
find out that the tree that fell and
almost killed the young vine count
wasn't an accident but that it was cut
down in an attempt to murder him the
entire film is set against the backdrop
of a giant reform bill that's about to
be passed
we aren't exactly sure what's in this
bill only that if passed it will allow
more people to vote
and will undoubtedly change the very
future of great britain
there's one thing this country doesn't
need it's more uneducated voters
it's this reform bill that sparks the
dowager to hire a hitman to kill her son
and grandson lord tewksbury is a liberal
who would vote for the bill
but if he were to be killed his uncle
would become lord and vote against the
bill
the dowager's way of life is at stake if
this bill were to pass and she's willing
to kill her own son and grandson to
maintain the status quo
as she says to anola earlier on as the
world becomes
increasingly unstable it feels important
that these
ideas of england are preserved when
enola is rescued from miss harrison's
school for young ladies by tewksbury
she has the choice to confront the
murderous dowager or
hide in london there'll come a time when
you have to make a hard choice
in that moment you will discover what
metal you truly have
and what you're prepared to risk
what matters the ability to have freedom
to make your own choices is one of the
film's biggest themes
like enola's choice to wear a corset
even though she says it represents
oppression
or her choice to go back and save the vi
count on the train
her choices define who she is as a
character and she's not gonna let
society dictate who she is
she's gonna make that choice for herself
the choice is always yours
whatever society may claim it can't
control you
the dowager reveals herself as the
film's real villain a relic of a country
still trying to hold on to its old ways
she shoots her grandson who we find
grabbed a piece of armor which protected
him from the bullets
and i'm kind of upset the film missed a
great opportunity for millie bobby brown
to go all jiu-jitsu on grandma i also
love tewksbury's last line to the
dowager
your time is over this line isn't just
directed to the dowager herself
but to everything she represents the old
ways of repression irreceptive to change
with the plot to kill young tewksbury
stymied he becomes the deciding vote in
the reform bill's passing as
britain moves into a new era of change
sherlock finds he's outsmarted not once
but
twice by his little sister first when
she solves the tewksbury case before he
does and twice
when she evades his plot to meet her
outside the royal academy
an institution known for not including
women but the final dramatic scene
belongs to anola and her
mother the person she spent almost the
entire movie trying to find
comes to her she says she left her
because i couldn't bear
to have this world be your future so i
had to fight
you have to make some noise if you want
to be heard
and that's what anola has done
throughout the film she's made noise
she's made change
she's learned that her life isn't
dictated by others and that by forging
her own path
the future is in her hands my life is my
own
and the future is up to us
thanks for watching everyone if you
enjoyed the video please make sure to
like and subscribe and for more bad
takes come follow me on twitter and
instagram
at thingstoryt until next time remember
daddy loves you very much